-I want to ask this -- You wer
in a film, "Doctor Sleep,"
which was an incredible sequel
to "The Shining."
and a story about a man
haunted by ghosts.
-Yeah.
-I am very skeptical of ghosts
but I do like asking guest
on the show.
You have had an encounter.
-I had one. It's a sort of lon
story that I'll try and shorten.
But when I was --
It was my 20th birthday.
And I was at drama school
in London.
And it was at Easter. And
Passover happened to be aligne
the same weekend, same day
And in the morning, my --
It was a student house.
And no one was there
'cause everyone had gone awa
for the holidays, except me.
And I watched this movie.
I stole someone's video recorder
from their room
to watch "Blue Velvet."
-Yeah.
-And after I had watched
"Blue Velvet,"
I was standing, running a bath
leaning in the doorway
in a robe.
And I was at
the top of the house.
My bedroom was at the top
of a staircase on its own.
And then there was a dark corr--
hallway with other bedrooms,
and then downstairs,
a bigger flat downstairs -
Apartment. Sorry.
Now I'm an American. Apartment
[ Laughter ]
And I was suddenly struck
with this pain on my back.
And I ripped off my robe.
And there was a big, black bur
mark on the back of my robe.
And I ran around, thinking
maybe when I got the video out
or something,
maybe there was a spark
or a fire or something happened.
-That's why we don't
have VCRs anymore.
-No, exactly. So I ran around,
thinking maybe I had caught fire
on something.
Nothing. Couldn't find anything.
I looked at the robe again
Now I see the whole back o
the robe was singed dark brown
and then this black burn mar
on my shoulder blade.
So I freaked out,
and I got out of there,
and I went and spent my birthday
with my uncle Dennis.
And the next day, I came back,
and the guy who owned the
apartment downstairs was back.
And I suddenly went, "Oh, yeah
this odd thing happened
the other night."
And his face went ashen.
And I said, "What is it?"
And he said, "No,
I don't want to tell you."
I said, "What is it?"
He said, "Look, the guy
who owned my flat downstairs
was an old, reclusive guy,
and he never went out.
He used to walk to the hedge and
sit at the hedge and go back in.
And his brother would come
'round two or three times a week
and give him a hot meal.
Otherwise, he didn't really eat.
Anyway, his brother got sick
one week, didn't come,
and the gentleman was
boiling a kettle in his kitchen.
And he was so hungry
that he fainted,
the kettle set fire
to his kitchen,
and he was burned on his back,
dragged out of the house,
and he died of his burns
to his back."
And I was like, "Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
I said, listen, you've got -
I thought he was --
We were actors, right? So
I thought, "He's making it up.
-Yeah.
-So he phoned up the landlady.
She told the story
so I could hear it.
She said, "But he was
a very nice man.
I'm sure he wouldn't
wish you any harm."
-Oh, she was like,
"He wouldn't be haunting you."
-He wouldn't be doing
anything nasty like that.
-And it was very clear
on the lease, "No haunting."
-"No burning."
[ Laughter ]
So, we went -- So I freaked out.
I said, "I'm not
sleeping up there.
I'm not sleeping in my room,
because I freaked out.
So we went down to his bedroom
I brought my bedding down.
And as we were walking
into his living room,
I said, "Look, I don't know --
I'll use the man's --
Say it was Mr. Goldblum,
for instance.
-Okay.
-I said, "Look --"
It was dirty.
We were drama students.
We didn't do much cleaning
I said, "It's as dirty as --
It's as dusty as when
Mr. Goldblum used to live here."
And I put my bedding
in the corner.
And I looked up,
and my friend was over there
And as I looked up,
the ceiling fell down like this.
The whole ceiling came down,
like, in a wave.
And there was this scream like
[High-pitched screaming]
which I realized was me.
[ Laughter ]
I was going, "It's okay!
It's just the ceiling!
It's the ceiling!
It's the ceiling!"
But two minutes later, I said,
"Lookit, we were just --"
I said, "Remember what I sai
about Mr. Goldblum?"
-Yeah.
-Everything was covered
in two inches of dust,
you know, plaster dust.
And then every night after that,
my door would open --
-Every night?
How many nights did you stay
-I think it was another -- I -
You know, I didn't have
any money to go anywhere else.
I had to stay there. But it wa
a good month or something.
The phone would ring. Nothing.
The door would squeak open
It was just all really scary
-I'm now maybe going to buy in
on ghosts are real.
-Well, I never saw him, or -
But that was just odd.
-It seems like that's
100 different signs.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, right now,
if he was watching,
he's like, "I didn't
say anything?! I'm a ghost!"
Hey, thank you so much for
being here. Always a pleasure.
Ewan McGregor, everybody.